[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non parce que je vous explique en fait
moi je suis maître chien en fait donc je
suis venu en tenue un ça va tout va bien
venu vérifier qu'on dépensait pas trop
c'est quoi cette lumière la table et
demande un buzzer pour les parterres ça
c'est une petite prime portable et c'est
moi qui la pétanque est pas les
chroniqueur yann est d'occuper les
autres c'est moi qui les paie et puis ça
c'est que des gens que j'ai fait venir
ils ont rien coûté la vie ça ça coûte
rien ça c'est des autres rien alors oui
il équipait le montiel ça coûte ça ne
lui c'est là qu'est ce qu on fait une
super émission je la regarde depuis tout
à l'heure
oui c'est à quel sujet mais il est c'est
david luiz
[Applaudissements]